in 1978 john carpenter's halloween was
released and became an instant hit that
spawned a huge horror franchise it's a
beloved classic but not everything in
the series was well received here are
examples of questionable storylines
with over 10 entries in the halloween
canon it can be challenging to remember
what has happened before any given movie
and that's not entirely the viewer's
fault halloween debuted in 1978 and by
the time halloween h2o 20 years later
was released in 1998 there were six
movies filled with different characters
instead of trying to tie together the
plots of all the films halloween h2o
retconned everything outside of the
original movie and its sequel in this
version of events films four through six
never occurred meaning lori strode never
had a secret daughter who michael myers
murdered instead laurie faked her death
assumed a new identity and had a son
nine years later rob zombie tried his
hand at making a halloween movie but he
started over with a rebooted completely
separate timeline creating his own
version of the characters when the
franchise returned in 2018 for a soft
reboot it erased everything except the
original halloween as if it were a
direct sequel 40 years in the making it
slightly addressed this in the 2018 film
when one character brings up plot points
from 1981's halloween 2 and is bluntly
told those were only rumors though the
branching arcs and characters may
intimidate new viewers at the end of the
day the series is still relatively
straightforward the strode family is
haunted by the trauma of the events of
the original halloween and a relentless
serial killer terrorizes the town of
haddenfield
halloween the curse of michael myers
starts with michael hunting down laurie
strode's 15 year old daughter jamie and
her newborn baby knowing michael is
after her jamie calls into a radio show
to ask michael's former psychiatrist dr
sam loomis for help she then immediately
hides her baby soon after michael finds
and kills jaime but her baby is found by
a grown-up tommy doyle the boy lori was
babysitting in the first film theorizing
that michael is intentionally targeting
members of his own family tommy does his
best to hide the infant from the killer
being the nigh unstoppable killing
machine he is michael eventually catches
up with the baby and in the fabled
producer's cut of the film a character
tries to stop michael from killing the
infant by suggesting it might be his
child since laurie is michael's sister
this presents the idea that he had a son
with his niece the implication of incest
is thankfully omitted in the theatrical
cut which without a doubt makes it the
stronger version given the uncomfortable
nature of this reveal it's probably
better to stick to the wider releases
story and pretend incest never happened
the hectic opening of halloween the
curse of michael myers should tip
viewers off right away that this will
not be an average entry in the franchise
a woman giving birth is surrounded by
doctors wheeling her gurney through an
industrial area then into a stone-carved
cavern lit with torches once the newborn
is delivered it's given to a mysterious
figure before the baby's mother has a
chance to hold him the infant is then
placed on a stone altar and has a symbol
drawn in red on its stomach surrounding
the newborn are three figures clad in
black robes it's unlike anything that's
been seen in a halloween film until this
point in the franchise these robed
figures are the movie's primary villains
and it's eventually revealed that this
cult has found a way to control michael
using an ancient rune of darkness known
as the thorn their claim seems to be
confirmed in the producer's cut when
tommy succeeds in halting michael's
rampage by using ancient runes of light
however thanks to difficulties with the
production the cult storyline never
fully took shape and it's no wonder that
future sequels let it go all together
though donald pleasence died
unexpectedly in 1995 he remains a
fixture of the halloween franchise
thanks to his character dr sam loomis
and his importance in the michael myers
story having been assigned to michael's
case dr loomis had 15 years to treat the
boy by the time of the first film he
decided michael was no longer a man but
evil in a human shape who had no chance
of redemption i realized that what was
living behind that boy's eyes was purely
and simply
evil from the moment michael escapes dr
loomis is hell-bent on taking michael
down by any means necessary this
includes blowing himself up traumatizing
children giving a bunch of locals
inferred permission to patrol the town
with rifles and holding police officers
at gunpoint throughout the series the
authority figures who interact with
loomis repeatedly dismiss the doctor and
underplay michael's threat to their
communities this isn't restricted to
police chiefs sheriffs or government
officials even the psychiatrist's
colleagues believe he should be
receiving mental health counseling
instead of dispensing it while he is
undoubtedly obsessive dr loomis is
almost always right whenever he suspects
michael is at large the only time dr
loomis is repeatedly wrong is in his
guesses of how to kill michael myers no
matter how many times he tried loomis
could never quite get rid of his least
favorite patient
there are numerous shots throughout the
halloween franchise of michael locking
eyes with his victims in a menacing
fashion these are always tense moments
as they often signal the victim
beginning to understand the danger
they're truly in these shots also have a
sort of calm before the storm vibe to
them focusing on stillness and inaction
to better punctuate the frantic fleeing
and stabbing that is usually about to
commence however one odd choice
throughout the franchise is the tendency
to follow a specific sequence of shots
in these interactions first the camera
shows michael staring at his victim what
follows is a reverse shot of the victim
looking at michael then the camera cuts
back to where the character is staring
only to show an empty michaelis space
sometimes this gives michael the
appearance of teleporting as the
character's gaze doesn't tend to follow
him to where he might have moved while
this is obviously an attempt by the
filmmakers to make michael myers more
threatening it actually raises more
questions than it answers in a matter of
seconds michael seemingly warps across
the room or safely off screen breaking
some of the tension that was previously
in the scene though it may admittedly be
awkward to watch michael walk from point
a to point b in every instance some
creative editing may help to make these
moments more believable by the time
halloween the curse of michael myers
happens 17 years have passed since
michael escaped from the institution in
which he was previously imprisoned for
15 years for murdering his older sister
upon obtaining his freedom he returned
to his hometown of haddenfield to attack
high school babysitter lori strode who
was later revealed to be his younger
sister this means michael's murders have
haunted the town for years however the
curse of michael myers is the first time
the holiday seems to have been curtailed
by the local government ahead of time in
fact when the film takes place
haddonfield residents are just beginning
to fight back against the restrictions
it seems odd that haddenfield would go
so far as to restrict the public
celebration of a holiday entirely and
especially odd that they only thought to
do it 30 some years after the first
meyer's murder aside from the two
halloweens where michael murdered one
sister then attempted to murder his
other one there have been several
incidents that probably should have been
on local officials radars in halloween 4
the return of michael myers one of the
local problems is that so many kids have
dressed up as their town's favorite
serial killer that it's hard to find the
real one a similar problem presents
itself in the following film the revenge
of michael myers where a local kid
dresses like michael as a joke allowing
people to mistake the real killer for a
teenager messing with his friends
instead of banning the whole holiday it
seems like banning the costume may have
been a better choice
rob zombie's halloween films are
contentious among fans of the franchise
while some admire the depth of backstory
from michael myers others find that the
characterization diminishes his impact
and is unnecessary however what most
fans agree on is that rob zombie's
halloween 2 is one of the most bizarre
entries in the series feeling much more
like a hyper stylized rob zombie acid
horror trip than a halloween film to
some extent zombies halloween 2 follows
similar story beats to the original
halloween 2. both films confirmed that
lori strode and michael myers are
siblings but unlike the original zombies
halloween 2 focuses more on the
psychological aspect of the characters
and delves into surrealist territory the
film features several hallucinations
that link the siblings minds including
scenes in which lori begins to envision
herself carrying out michael's past
murders eventually laurie is sent to an
institution similar to the one that held
her brother for 15 years here we see the
most outlandish imagery in the entirety
of the halloween franchise a
hallucination of a white horse that
feels more akin to a fantasy film than
something that should be in halloween
too overall zombies halloween 2 is one
of the oddest films in the franchise and
the abstract nature of the movie is
often forgotten or ignored when
discussing some of the latter more
disliked films in the series
one of the most effective ways to make a
horror film scary is through clever
sound design most people familiar with
jump scares know that music and sound
effects are frequently used to get a
reaction out of audience members beyond
jump scares and the use of a film's
score sound effects that aren't made to
scare in and of themselves can be hugely
effective in ratcheting up the tension
of any given scene for instance the
metallic shing of a knife as it's drawn
helps reinforce its sharpness in the
mind of audience members and the loud
thwack that rings out when the same
blade is plunged into its target can
make the impact seem much more
terrifying than the visual alone with so
much potential to enhance the mood of a
scene the misuse of sound effects is
often glaring and can take the viewer
right out of the movie while the
halloween films generally use sound
effects well there are a few
unforgettable instances where they feel
distinctly out of place the best example
of this is found in halloween 5 the
revenge of michael myers during a
comedic scene between two police
officers a series of clown sound effects
including honking are played during
their banter without any explanation
fortunately we're lousy cops
sorry halloween resurrection features a
group of teens wandering around the
abandoned myers house on a halloween
night as part of an internet live stream
this reality show functions by having
all the cameras accessible for audiences
to watch at any time and the contestant
that most viewers choose to watch is the
winner however little do the
participants or the show's producers
know that michael myers has made his way
back to his childhood home and he's
ready to kill anyone he gets his hands
on when it becomes clear to audiences
that contestants are actually being
murdered and aren't playing pranks on
the others for views the mood inside and
outside the house becomes less
lighthearted luckily one contestant has
a friend watching who texts her
michael's location while checking other
cameras this ends up saving her life a
couple of times and even earns the guy a
shout out once reporters show up to get
a statement from the survivor who's
still wrapped in a shock blanket while
this works well for the characters in
the film it seems a bit suspect that a
live stream with upwards of a dozen
cameras all broadcasting live would have
no lag while operating within a small
illinois town's 2002 internet
infrastructure aside from having
instantaneous uploading there also
appears to be no issue with buffering or
loading on the viewing end as up to the
second info on michael is sent via text
even if the show was done today there
would likely be at least a several
second long delay for viewers at home
and certainly a few more seconds to wait
for a text message to send check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite horror movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]